now if you have a problem against a
standard game then you came to the right
place as in today's lecture I'm going to
show you not only a tricky line against
it but in the majority of the cases you
will see that it is black who will get
lot of fun in this line
[Music]
okay the opening arises after the
following move order E4 E5 D4
e captures D4 and now white capture back
with the queen allowing us to take the
tempo with Knight to C6 but his idea is
that after Queen to E3
as I have highlighted by the arrows here
that
most likely white is trying to plan to
Castle coincide whereupon black is
trying to Castle on the king side and we
have a very interesting battle going on
in the middle cave
so for example the main line start with
Knight to F6 Knight to C3
Bishop to B4 Bishop to D2 and now as
expected both the side Castle on the
opposite direction
whereupon Rook to E8 is set the stage
for the upcoming fire
now if you check the database here
majority of the cases white has tried
this three options and let's see each by
turn and find out how we are going to
conquer them
the first move I want to consider is the
most popular Queen G3
so white is immediately looking for some
attacking aspects
but the big time problem is it costs the
center Pawn which we are more than happy
to grab it with overnight
so now as this Knight is attacking three
locations white response is force he has
to take it
and after Rook takes E4
if white exchange the bishop then more
exchange helps black as he is a clear
Pawn up
so nope that's not the big point
the main idea is white wants to play C3
attacking the bishop
and then carry out his rapid fast
development
well if you check the database here by
far the most popular choice is Bishop to
f8
however I think it's an inaccurate
choice and
as suggested by modern chess engine
black should go ahead with Bishop to E7
which has a very nasty idea that when
white plays Bishop to D3 looks scary at
the first sight black has a nice
in-between move in this picture namely
Bishop to H4
the point is you get rid of the queen
from the G file
so that now you can comfortably take the
Rook back on the E8 and if allowed then
black has a very simple plan namely D6
and then settle this bishop on F6
whereupon he is a clear point of and it
is wide who has to demonstrate what he
is going to do about it
well to illustrate my point I like to
show you a recent game of mine against
2300
where
my opponent continued with Queen to H5
looking at the juicy at seven square
so I have to defend it with G6
and his idea is
he wants to put Queen right into my king
side with Queen 286.
but apparently white doesn't have any
thread so I continue with some natural
moves Knight to V5 attacking the bishop
Bishop dropped back to C2 and now last
piece liberated with D6
well my opponent was desperate for the
attack so he played Knight to F3 hoping
that I will take it and open up the G
file but believe it or not this is
exactly black did with Knight captures
F3 G captures F3 and the Big Time
pointer is black wants to play Rook to
E5 and then
attacked the White's pesky Queen
well my opponent played the equally
sneaky move that is Rook to G1 so that
now Rook to H5 is not a possibility as
white can simply take it
but unfortunately for white after this
game finished very quickly with the
following easy sequence
Bishop captures F2 attacking The Rook
Rook to G2 and now the straightforward
approach yup when you are material up
just try to exchange the queen so that
a queenless middle game is always
hopeless for the side who has less
material
okay my opponent has no choice he can't
deny it so he tried to move Queen to F4
but now black Pieces come out very
freely Bishop to H3 attacking the Rogue
Rook to G5 has been played but then
black make the game very easy Queen
exchange and then
exchange The Rook whereupon the end
result is black is emerge with a clear
two-point advantage and white has
absolutely no compensation for it
so I think this model game gives you a
good illustration
how comfortably black placed once he
continued with Bishop to E7
the second move I want to consider is F3
which looks more natural in this
position you try to defend the pawn and
then go for the king side assault
but it comes with a cost and that is
black can play the move D5 here putting
more pressure on the E bone
okay if you look at the database by far
the most popular choice is Queen to F2
getting out of the PIN
but then black is more than happy to
take it off as after the critical move
Bishop to G5
black has a nasty surprise in this
position
well I don't like the Top Choice in the
database that is Queen to E7 I think
after this black doesn't have good
position so instead of this my
recommendation is you continue with this
very sneaky move Bishop to D7 which sets
up some cool tricky platform for the
white Cam
for example white cannot take on F6
looks like obvious choice as black
cannot capture back with the queen and
if he capture back with the pawn then
his King side has been compromised But
Here Comes the big idea
black indeed capture with the queen
allowing white to take the free Bishop
but the big time pointers after Bishop
takes C3 Pawn takes E3 and the move E3
no matter how Wayward White wriggles
he cannot get out of this Mass
for example a recent game from the
database white continued with Queen to
even
defending the C3 Pawn
black plays obvious choice Queen to E6
double attack and after Rook to D3 black
indeed gobble up on A2 whereupon at the
end Rook captures E3 Rook takes Queen
takes and now comes this lethal check
which not only gobble up the piece back
but white King has been stuck in the
center and black can have all sorts of
fun from here
so this is the reason why Bishop
captures the F6 straight away leads to
winning position for the black
by far the most popular choice from here
is Knight to D5 and it looks more
logical as you pressurizing the F6
Knight
but black has equally nice reply
starting with
E3 attacking the queen
doesn't look good at first sight as
white can play the move Queen to H4 and
put more pressure on up six but it has a
valid point and that is
this amazing chat which believe it or
not but gives black an opening advantage
nope can't take this bishop because
after Pawn takes D2 white has two
options whether to take the spawn or
play King to D1 and in both the case he
get a completely losing plot
for example if you play King captures D2
here then black has a simple reply
Bishop to E6 spinning down this Knight
and after C4
everything get exchanged Bishop takes
Bishop takes F6 Pawn takes F6 Pawn takes
D5 Queen captures D5 and after King to
C1 and the move Rook to d8
obvious enough
black is an exchanger and he has some
clear highways to launch the Bombshells
on the white king
so that is the reason why King captures
D2 is a bad choice here
the more accurate choice is King to D1
but against this I propose this nice
Queen sacrifice
starting with Knight captures D5 and
once again white is losing a piece in a
broad daylight as if he takes the queen
then after the following sequence Knight
to E3 check
King captures D2 Knight captures F1
check
King to 7 and now simple move Rook
captures d8 whereupon the end result is
we get three PCS against Queen which is
always a good trade especially when the
white king looks so shaky and alone at
one-sided of the ball
so nope Rook captures D2 is a bad idea
and that is why as per the database the
most popular choice is King to B1
but after this black has a nice
surprising move here namely Bishop to F5
the big time point is
you are defending on at seven so Bishop
captures F6 is completely ruled out and
majority of the games continue with
Knight captures F6 whereupon G captures
F6 Bishop captures F6
and now very nice move Queen to D6 so
that the queen can comes into the
defense from the effort Square
once again let's see a game between two
grand Masters where white continued with
Queen 286 trying to check mid black
played Queen to f8
and after Queen to G5 he calmly
retrieved the bishop back to the G6
Square
well white would love to play H4 only to
find out that he cannot as after the
move E2 attacking the queen
what is forced to capture the bishop
whereupon the end result is
not only we are exchange up at this
position but after amazing reply Queen
to D6 white is going to lose yet another
piece as he cannot take this queen in
the view of Rook to even
back rank issues on the board
so you can see how difficult these
positions are for the wide and instead
of H4 in the game white indeed played
the Moon Knight to E2
stopping Black's E2 idea but this
doesn't solve the problem as Black come
up with this nice sequence night to
before
threatening C2 which unfortunately white
cannot defend it so he decided to sack
the exchange with Rook captures D2 Pawn
captures D2 Queen captures D2
but now this just invite black Rook to
come into the picture immediately with
Rook a to d8
sacking back the exchange but more
importantly get the initiative so that
after Queen to even
Knight captures C2
Queen to C1
and now the lovely finish
did you spot it
yup it's Knight to E3 a discover check
and after King to even and The Rook to
D1
white fine nothing better than resigned
the game
so I think this tricky analysis and the
model games give you a great idea
how easy black play is if white continue
with the move F3
last but not least
what to do against the move Bishop to C4
which I personally think is one of the
best response by the White
and against this I recommend this very
simple approach starting with D6
well if your opponent plays Knight to F3
then Bishop to G4 is a very strong reply
and I have attached my model game in
this line
but if you look at the database here by
far the most popular choice is F3
whereupon once again black get
tremendous fun against it
first we start with Knight to E5
attacking the bishop
Bishop to B3 and now what else but
attack the white king starting with A5
recently a 2600 white player
got crossed within just 22 moves and I
like to show you that game to illustrate
how dangerous this line is
as white played some natural moves such
as A3 attacking the bishop but after
Bishop to C5
Queen to even and now starmu in the
picture B5
and if you run this in any chess engine
it is already saying that white should
pack his bag and go home
doesn't look like right but see yourself
well the threat is very obvious you want
to play B4 and rip open the White Queen
side
so why not take it and that is exactly
2600 does in the game
but now the task becomes so easy black
fast play A4 attacking the bishop Bishop
to A2 now another piece get attacked
with C6 and after Knight to C3 and the
move Queen to B6
I think white has a disgusting position
black has a very simple plan that is
rooked to be it and Checkmate white king
and even though white can see that one
is coming unfortunately he cannot defend
it
well in the game he tried Knight to E2
but after Bishop to E6
Bishop takes and now very nice move Rook
to B8
confirms black Victory on the ball
Why Try to defend his position with B3
so that after a captures B3 he can
recapture back with the bishop
but now black drop
bombshell
Can you spot it
you are a genius if you see the move
Knight to D3 fish destroy all the White
Hope
the point is his Queen is hanging so he
has to take it
but then we have a forcing Checkmate
sequence on the bone
starting with
Bishop takes King B1
quintix B3 King to A1 and now Queen to
B2
a lovely picturesque checkmate at just
22 moves on the board
where amazing part is white hasn't even
start an attack on the black cake
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile tricky lines against the
center game
remember after Rook to E8 it doesn't
matter however white response as I have
shown in the video not only black has
some nice nuances with some tricky
business on the board and even though
white is booked up with his theoretical
moves
with some nice preparation black opening
Advantage cannot be denied
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon
buy and take care